[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue à tous dans ce set
8 les invités une émission dédiée à
celles et ceux qui font l'actualité dans
le département est aujourd'hui mercredi
17 mai parole à laurent carle le chef
d'établissement du centre horticole
d'enseignement et de promotion aussi
appelé le chef le chef et qui participe
le week-end prochain à la 11e édition de
la fête de la nature nous évoquerons
également avec l'ouverture prochaine
d'une nouvelle filière rochette un bac
professionnel forêt parole aussi dans
cette émission à fabienne thibeault au
personnage mythique de la comédie
musicale starmania celle qui
interprétait marie jeanne la serveuse
automate sera à rambouillet dans
quelques jours pour un concert caritatif
mais pour débuter cette émission je me
tourne vers laurent carle bonsoir vous
êtes jeu le disiez le directeur du chef
le centre horticole d'enseignement et de
promotion
un établissement qui est basée à
tremblay sur mauldre et vous êtes en
plateau pour nous parler notamment de
votre participation samedi à la 11e
édition de la fête de la nature et pour
vous désormais c'est un rendez-vous j'en
veux dire habituel c'est un rituel et
puis c'est logique aussi pour vous de
participer à cette fête de la nature
c'est effectivement un rituel et on ne
peut que se féliciter que chaque année
nous avons de plus en plus de visiteurs
et de par nos activités tant sur le
paysage l'environnement et pour demain
la forêt c'est vrai que ça fait un écho
tout à fait pertinent avec cet événement
national qui regroupe chaque année bon
nombre de milliers de personnes qui
viennent au contact de la nature alors
la fête de la nature c'est du 17 au 21
mai mais chez vous c'est principalement
le 20 mai uniquement à la journée du 20
mai samedi 20 mai de 9h à 17h autour du
thème de cette édition les super
pouvoirs de la nature n'aura l'occasion
de revenir dessus et vous proposer aux
chefs de découvrir d'ailleurs les super
pouvoirs des animaux en se mettant dans
la peau des animaux ce que vous pouvez
nous expliquer surtout nous dévoiler
qu'est ce qui sera proposé
effectivement je me suis dit pas tout
dévoiler pour que ça reste vraiment
attractif c'est vrai que la nature est
tellement bien fait que effectivement on
peut parler de super pouvoirs et donc il
y aura des ateliers
pour expliquer pour montrer pour sous
forme notamment ludiques à destination
des jeunes et des moins jeunes
on peut essayer de déterminer
concrètement en quoi ses superpouvoirs
peuvent-ils faire référence à un indice
par exemple voilà un exemple et ben en
voilà un petit exemple les bains le
faucon pèlerin par exemple et ben 390 km
heure 380 voilà c'est bien aussi si ça
c'est pas super pouvoirs voilà également
un autre petit indice on connaît pour
les initier au moins la barben et bien
les fruits de la bardane c'est ce qui a
inspiré l'inventeur du velcro d'accord
et c'est également un super pouvoir
voilà et puis je vais pas forcément tout
dévoiler aujourd'hui mais quand on parle
également de l'orage des éclairs cette
énergie monumentale et en quelques
secondes se déchaînent c'est également
assez fabuleux quand même est-ce que ça
veut dire que le samedi on pourra aller
à 390 km heure si on se met dans la peau
d'un aigle noir évidemment jeté film et
plus ayant voilà il y aura beaucoup
d'informations comme celle ci durant
cette journée on prend aussi découvrir
grâce au chef votre mari qu'est-ce qu'on
pourra découvrir dans ce marais de quoi
est il constitué
nous avons la chance effectivement sur
le site du tremblay d'avoir une dizaine
d'hectares d'espacés naturels et dont
une zone humide est effectivement amar
et donc découverte bien sûr des
amphibiens des batraciens mais également
de plantes je pense à la mouche je pense
aux orties
critique un duo rica ça fait un peu un
écho aussi aux superpouvoirs parce que
l'ortie cadbury quelque chose à
exploiter également à déguster puisque
c'est également une base de plats qui
sont très intéressants on va justement
parlé de la dégustation mais pour
revenir sur cet atelier notamment on
pourra créer des pièges pour frelon
asiatique
expliquez-nous pourquoi il faut les
piégés entre guillemets les coincés ils
sont les nuisibles pour la nature les
frelons asiatiques aujourd'hui comme le
nom l'indiqué frelon asiatique c'est
donc pas les frelons français appellent
également frôlé en commun ils viennent
un pays asiatique
et malheureusement ils participent à la
chute des populations de dessin
d'abeilles donc but de fait des ruches
est tout simplement en venant et on en
mangeait les abeilles devant les ruches
en les attrapant et en allant les
déguster un peu plus loin ou dans leur
nid et cette espèce a la particularité
d'être extrêmement prolifique et
malheureusement au grand dam des
apiculteurs parce que chaque année il
faut arriver à déterminer où peuvent-ils
se nicher bien souvent hautes cimes
d'arbres mais quand la végétation se
fait jour et de fait c'est compliqué
l'attraper et l'idée c'est bien sûr de
pouvoir en amont essaie d'attraper les
rênes avant même qu'elles puissent se
faire exactement
autre animation qui va je suis sûr
intéressé et interroger ceux qui nous
regardent et qui nous écoutent ce soir
dégustation de plantes alors vous en
parler un petit peu avec moi ce que vous
pouvez aussi là nous détailler
l'animation écoutez l'animation on part
d'éléments de récolte
sur le lieu du site du tremblay par
exemple de plantes végétale ou de
plantes qui comme je disais tout à
l'heure
lortie par exemple les bains peut se
préparer à diverses plat étant souple
que en gratin que avec derrière des
objectifs également culinaire mais
également de santé puisque il y a des
vocations bien reconnu sur laon les
enjeux notamment avec les vitamines et
106 etc et donc voilà des vraiment je
sais rien je reste sur lüthi sur l'ortie
est content parce que on l'abordé puis
je souhaite que les bleus public
découvre les autres les autres blanc
tant d'autres mais voilà c'est un
concours donnez à l'idée voilà de ce que
nous allons pouvoir découvrir en venant
nous voir le salon oui il y aura plein
d'informations à découvrir
il y aura également par exemple un
atelier photo pour apprendre à
photographier les plus petits insectes
on aura aussi de la pêche à la truite au
canada on est un petit peu pris par le
temps du coup je voudrais passer au
second sujet pour de votre venue
le chef aujourd'hui ses 70 ans
d'expérience de nombreuses formations
pour apprendre des métiers du paysage ou
de l'environnement et une nouvelle
filière à la rentrée 2010 est c'est une
première de notre région un bac pro
forêt de quoi s'agit-il est acquis et il
est destiné
alors bac pro forêt comme son nom
l'indiqué l'idée c'est de pouvoir former
les jeunes pour ensuite intervenir sur
la filière forestière en ile-de-france
et voir après bien sûr dans nos
départements au niveau national ce qu'il
faut savoir c'est que c'est une filière
qui est méconnu à l'instar
pour autant des surfaces qui sont
considérés en ile de france et plus de
270 mille hectares c'est plus d'un quart
du territoire ile-de-france qui est
couvert par des massifs forestiers celle
peu connus on a en tête le massif de de
la forêt de rambouillet le massif
forestier de la forêt de fontainebleau
mais il ya aussi celle de saint germain
de versailles de meudon aujourd'hui à un
manque de madoff alors il a concrètement
à un manque de main d'oeuvre les
entreprises d'exploitation forestière et
où les services de l'eau nf recherche
des personnes compétentes et au delà de
ces personnes compétentes pointé à venir
vraiment sur le terrain on cherche
également des gestionnaires parce que il
faut réaliser des plans de gestion
forestier notamment à destination des
massifs forestiers qui appartiennent à
des privés
c'est plus de 70 % des surfaces ont
indiqué tout à l'heure qui appartiennent
à des particuliers dont il ya des privés
et pour ses surfaces là à ce jour il
n'ya pas d'exploitation et il n'y a pas
de gestion ou peut donc l'idée c'est
vraiment de pouvoir être acteur dans
cette dynamique émergente
demain le bois oeuvre le bois énergie le
bois construction
il sera il est et il sera en plein essor
et donc de fait c'est de pouvoir
accompagner le monde professionnel et
les différents acteurs pour ses
prochaines décennies tant sur la
formation que sur l'insertion de
profession et vous allez du coup
présenté cette nouvelle filière qui va
se lancer en 2017 ce samedi c'est aussi
du coup pour les jeunes intéressés sera
probablement des débouchés certains et
de une vie professionnelle certaines
exactement on peut retrouver toutes ces
informations d'ailleurs sur votre site
indisponible deux voilées contre w point
chez ep 78 point fr merci laurent carle
d'être venu en plateau vous êtes le chef
d'établissement je me rappelle du centre
horticole d'enseignement basée dans les
yvelines
merci beaucoup merci à vous on poursuit
cette émission avec du chant et des
souvenirs probablement pour beaucoup
d'entre vous en 1978 fabienne thibeault
interpréter la toute première
marie-jeanne dans starmania quarante ans
plus tard la chanteuse franco québécoise
interprétera les plus grands titres de
la comédie musicale le 7 juin prochain
au nickel de rambouillet une soirée au
profit du lion de ce club local mélanie
pau qui a rencontré la chanteuse
fabienne thibeault bonjour
pourquoi avez vous accepté de chanter
lors de cette soirée
d'abord parce que la président de nous
inscrire d'europe comme ça comme ça est
une amie parce que j'ai de nombreux amis
on rembobine et parce que j'ai beaucoup
de respect pour retenu ans parce que
l'universel ordinaire a fêté et parce
que je pense que chance pour l'instant
grille à son comble hier avec leur
génération
il ya l'aspect solidarité ce soir avec
notamment le financement d'un véhicule
c'était ça aussi qui vous emporte et
outre le fait de chanter même importante
ça fait partie du projet n'est ce pas
que cette mise à disposition la vie
qu'une prise à ça alors je pense que
c'est principalement pour les
personnages et les gamins qui vont en
profiter
c'est normal ça permet au cinéma je les
quartiers sa ferme et 2
dany
les artisans les commerçants et d'être
les marchés importants dans le quotidien
économique et l'activité nous si vous
disiez il va y avoir des titres de
starmania que vous allez chanter quelle
place à cette comédie musicale donc
votre vie à moi starmania complètement
fondatrice de même c'est à partir de
starmania cloud public marche revenus ma
rencontre et ma cheville
starmania et tintin vraiment un
patrimoine de notre culture populaire
musicale beaucoup de tubes beaucoup de
pommes aussi sur le trait est
extrêmement et fondateur de ce qu'on vit
aujourd'hui dans le bon comme dans le
moins bon
d'ailleurs on
quand donald trump haïti beaucoup de
gens ont ruiné ses 0 janvier le
businessman qui donne au président qui
aime les personnages de starmania avec
la chanson blues du businessman qui est
d'ailleurs interprété dans le spectacle
face aux superbes les spectacles que
vous proposerez le 7 juin s'appelle du
québec à starmania le québec une autre
histoire de votre fille il n'y aura dans
cette fnac évidemment quelle que soit en
grand et champion du québec
les français connaissent et aiment de
félix leclerc à charlebois de la
complice fois galliani frais langage les
collectionner je vais voir parce que il
ya aussi du moment d'allocutions doit
tout aux besoins tiennent comme la
construction ou à quelques une grange
une faute de quoi c'est la fin de ce set
8 les rendez vous pour ce soir prochain
rendez vous demain même heure d'ici là
retrouvez toutes nos séquences sur notre
site internet tv fil 78 points comme ou
l'application tv fil 78
bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]